Civic leaders and grassroots organizations played a major role
in revitalizing the city. Downtown Rochester saw new investments in housing,
restaurants, art spaces, and green infrastructure.
Empty factories were repurposed into housing, galleries, and new office spaces.
Cultural institutions such as the Strong Museum of Play and the Rochester
Philharmonic helped re-energize the arts and tourism scenes.
Importantly, the community began focusing more on inclusion and equity,
recognizing that the old industrial model had often left behind marginalized
communities, the city launched initiatives to promote workforce development,
access to education, and affordable housing.
Efforts to bridge the digital divide support minority-owned businesses
and reinvest and underserved neighborhoods have been part of Rochester's broader efforts
to ensure that its resurgence benefits all residents, not just a privileged few.